foreign
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist I've
got with me my co-host Chuck Nice and
together we welcome my friend and
colleague Michio Kaku who's a professor
of theoretical physics at the City
College of New York and he just
published a book titled Quantum
Supremacy
and we're taking questions from our
patreon members Chuck what's the first
question up that you got all right
here's Daniel
kilikowski or kulakowski that's probably
Daniel kulakowski who says hello Dr
Tyson Dr Kaku and I will assume Lord
nice from the Research Triangle of North
Carolina I hail and I would like to ask
what would you say is the biggest
National Security consideration of
quantum Computing technology oh I love
it yeah good all right what do you got
going there
well the biggest national security
question about quantum computers is the
fact that the CIA will be put out of
business all security people would be
fired because all the secrets all the
secrets would be open to anybody with a
quantum computer any teenager with a
quantum computer would be able to tap
into you know the crown jewels wait wait
I try to log into my own bank account if
I get the password wrong three times it
locks me out and I have to call in to
get re-established so how is it that a
quantum computer can get into my bank
account by testing a billion zillion
squillion passwords and I can't because
I'm I mess up I got fat thumbs three
times in a row
well if you want to break into a
computer of a bank the first thing the
computer asks you for is to factorize
this number this number has maybe a
hundred digits and how long will it take
you to factorize a number with 100
digits a few thousand years
so in other words yeah you could break
into a regular bank but it would take a
few thousand years to do that with a
quantum computer you could do that with
the flick of a dial
that's the power by because the computer
asks you please factorize this number if
you could wait no computer has ever
asked me to do that are you saying
that's happening under the hood
if that if that were the starter
question nobody would have any access to
any computer at all so is that just
happening under the hood and by the way
that's why I never turned on uh my uh
two-factor oh you're worried you'll get
locked out if you have a password of
let's say six digits how long would it
take for a computer to go through every
single one of those six digits this is
my point when I mess up three times I'm
locked out for for an hour all right so
why do I believe that it can blow
through a bajillion squillion attempts
and then get in why should I believe
because this is not how the average
person gets into a site this is how the
banks monitor who comes into the site
this is how this is what the big boys do
when they start to talk to each other
um
it's under the hood Okay so all right no
but maybe it's not that the CIA will go
out of business or all security we've
got a business it's that we came up with
this this security protocol knowing it
was Out Of Reach of traditional
Computing so surely there's another
security protocol where Quantum
Computing would take a thousand years
isn't there or not well so far the
highest level of security is done by
factorization okay but thanks talk to
each other it was invented because we
knew it was hard for computers so it
you're smart come up with something else
what will come after factorization and
you know what would here's a better
question
how would I stop a quantum computer from
getting into my stuff right
with a gun okay
was this America stop you at the front
steps
so I suppose patriotic answer you can
have
wait so Michio just seems to me we have
smart people out there they come up with
some other task that would be damn near
impossible or forever task even for
quantum computers there's bound to be
something right if you could find it in
patented or copyrighted it'd be a rich
man right okay because it's the early
days you're right you're right it's the
world economy it rests on this the
answer to this question the world
economy oh wow okay you could break into
anything you want if you had a way to
get around some of these protocols so so
now we know what the real motivation for
this race is
now we know what it is it's money it's
money he who rules the quantum computer
rules the world economy rules the world
economy that's crazy that's why people
work on it that's why he wrote the book
hey look look this is coming very fast
hey guys apologies for the interruption
I wanted to take a quick break and thank
our partners at ag1 for sponsoring
today's video now for those of you who
don't know ag1 is a foundational
nutritional supplement that supports
whole body Health made up of 75 high
quality ingredients ag-1 not only
supports immunity especially during my
busiest days it also replenishes the
nutrients in our bodies and it balances
mood and stress levels like those times
when my kids are getting on my nerves
but just don't take it from me ag1 is
made up of the highest quality
ingredient and this even NSF certified
for sport meaning it's approved by some
of the strictest regulations in
professional sports now I'm a little
consumer of ag1 but what I love is they
make it so simple all you have to do is
toss in a scoop now I like to use almond
milk and then of course you give it a
little Shake
and
um
all right it tastes good too I'm telling
you guys it doesn't get any easier than
this so listen if you are interested in
trying this for yourself visit drink
ag1.com star talk to get a free one-year
supply of AG vitamin D3 plus K2 and 5
A.G travel packs with your first
purchase thanks again to our friends at
ag1 for sponsoring today's video and
giving me some delicious nutrition
this is your book Quantum Supremacy
that's the title of your damn book yeah
Quantum Supremacy that's right Quantum
Computing will change everything
wow all right Chuck you've got another
question
this is Gavin bomber uh from North
Vancouver and he says hello and please
visit uh he's lonely up there I don't
know exactly if anyone identifies their
location in Canada as north of anything
it's got to be cold and lonely yeah
because most of the Canadian population
is like right at the border right the
United States right so that makes sense
yeah North Vancouver he says um
how is quantum Computing going to be
used to help solve the climate crisis oh
I like that that's a really great good
one yeah what what are we not being able
to compute that Quantum Computing will
do for us we'll make better weather
models better climate models that's one
thing I realize that when you model the
Earth how do you model the planet Earth
you divide the atmosphere into cubes and
then you calculate the weather in each
Cube and then you average it over the
entire Earth that's how you calculate
the weather of the future now
each how big is HQ each cube is several
miles across now you say to yourself
what if each data point is a few miles
across you can't trust any of these
results and that's the problem well
that's because something could be
happening at the edge of the Mile right
and they'll average it into where you
are and it won't apply okay so that
means you want smaller cubes more cubes
that's right that's what quantum
computers comes in because they are
indefinitely more powerful the the
things that they manipulate are not
zeros and well I'm zeros and ones for
each 10 Mile Cube no they are infinitely
small and so now you begin to realize
the power of this technique we're going
down to the molecular scale we're going
down to a scale that is unreachable with
digital computers so Eeyore was ahead of
his time do you remember Eeyore the ER
from Winnie the Pooh the donkey I think
it's your he has a cloud that's raining
just over him yeah
so whatever the weather modeling the
cube is small enough to just affect the
donkey and nobody else that's that's the
kind of weather Precision you're talking
about here right and you know when a
hurricane is about to hit Florida they
have all the projections of where it's
going to hit landfall and then you see
all the different kinds of trajectories
they're way off they're way off and
these are the best computers that we
have well in all fairness they start
close to each other and then they
diverge diverge over time how reliable
is that right quantum computer you
should be able to get much much better
numbers because of the fact that each
Cube that you're averaging over is not
10 miles across but maybe a few feet
across
my favorite Trump joke ever was
um that Trump only got interested in
climate change and and whether when he
found out that they model uh that the
hurricane used European models yeah
that's actually a good joke that's a
good joke I don't take credit for that
but um so Mitchell white the Europeans
had what different computing power or
different ideas about how weather
systems would operate relative to we
here across the pond each computer
program has a different way of chopping
up the Earth in terms of cubes and then
within each Cube using equations to
model the weather in each individual
Cube and then lastly to then wrap all
these cubes together to get the weather
of the entire Earth that's a lot of
assumptions that's a lot of models and
that's why we can never predict the
exact path of a hurricane you see that
every time I just wouldn't have thought
that a continent would have its own set
of models relative to another continent
that's all that seemed that seemed kind
of provincial to me
well you got it the Euro model
digital computers are very provisional
all right meet you it's great we got
your book out uh Quantum Supremacy
audacious of you to title it that I mean
I don't want that to be true but we know
that's what it's about and no we know
we're just being that's the name of the
game yeah that's the name of the game
better than the Bourne Supremacy
[Laughter]
Chuck one last question see if we can
fit one in all right this is David
hey David here from upstate New York hi
to all I don't think Adele and HP will
be selling quantum computers at Walmarts
anytime soon and that's what concerns me
the most Quantum Computing will most
likely be used by large corporations and
governments and the ultra wealthy
between Ai and advanced Quantum
Computing and you describe one benefit
it will bring to me the average person
do you think it will unite Humanity
divide us further into Havens and haves
and have-nots please
thank you in advance
well all right all Technologies when
they are first invented usually benefit
the people who invested in it which are
usually wealthy people people with
connections but then mass production
kicks in competition kicks in prices
start to go down as a consequence but
every technology name them all going
back to the Stone Age the first people
to introduce Technologies had the
advantage and they used it to get rich
or to be part of it is true wheels are
pretty cheap today right
same thing with quantum computers
eventually we'll all have it shipped for
example in our contact lens we'll have a
connection to the internet in the cloud
the quantum computers will be in the
cloud and your you will access it with
your wristwatch your contact lens you'll
blink and then you'll have access to the
computing power or the implant or the
neural implant right or the neural
implant that's right you simply think
and you get access to a quantum computer
but first all right initially yeah it's
going to be the big bank and the CIA and
people like that that'll be jumping on
the computer uh uh quantum computer bad
wagon but then prices will begin to drop
because of competition mass production
and they've always dropped for
everything else so that's the reason why
you say that that's right and how
quickly is this 10 years from now 20
years five years well right now we we
already have achieved Quantum Supremacy
that's already been achieved but not for
general questions that's what we want an
all-purpose quantum computer for any
general question that'll take maybe
another 10 years another 10 years we're
going exponentially fast we're up to a
thousand qubits now that was unheard of
if you were to talk to somebody just 10
years ago they'd shake their heads what
you'd be lucky to have four or five
qubits now we're up to a thousand
eventually we'll be up to a million
all right and then when you come back on
the show you will be an animatronic
hologram it'll just be his Consciousness
inside of him you know some kind of
position plasma cloud or just a jar I'll
be an avatar
so that was just a taste of a much
longer conversation StarTalk had with
Michio Kaku friend and professor of
physics at the City University of New
York
check it out on Starcon
foreign
[Music]